[Applause]
hello everyone and i am bang chan and
i'm back with buzzfeed
hi guys i'm nino nice to meet you hi
guys i'm champion nice to meet you too
hi
and we're here with buzzfeed finally to
rank all of our songs to find out which
strike his song is our actual favorite
so here's how it's going to work okay
all of our songs are spread out in a
bracket paired against each other with
each pairing we'll have to decide
together as a group which song we like
more to move on to the next round so
it's like a tournament okay
so the last song remaining will be the
winner and our personal favorite
straight kids song wow
beautiful beautiful okay
number one cheese versus thundurus
one two three
me know all right now the next one the
view versus sorry i love it
one two three sorry i love you
sorry i love you sorry i love chunky
sorry okay all right next we have silent
cry and secret secret oh that sounded
crazy
well what about secret secret it's your
song it's your song oh my god secret
secret is so amazing
i love this song that's so beautiful
second question
secrecy
i love okay secret secret okay
all right one two three
double secret star lost and the tortoise
and the hail oh
wait a minute
oh
do you feel like star lost i love star
wars
all four people oh my people yeah
one two three
yeah
one two three
beautiful all right next we have any ani
or x
oh wait oh i like yeah
yeah all right next up we have
pacemaker versus
oh
okay
all right next we have blueprint and top
top
oh yeah
tell me what do you like i love one
track too
me hello
damian
oh my god
um
all right one two three elevator next we
have my pace and i am you know oh
five six seven five
five five six seven nice
mine
next we have mirror and side effects
all right one two three
okay now next up we have elevator versus
my pace
one two three elevator beautiful days
and oh
next up we have airplane and top oh
all right next up we have god's menu and
x oh sorry sorry it's really good
all right one two three
sorry i love you and see chris and craig
[Applause]
okay okay okay next up depends up you
feel secret secret
sorry i love secrets okay
all right
come here pipe it up yeah you ready
[Music]
uh
thunders or secrets
wow
i'm sorry i'm sorry
right now we are going to the semifinals
one two three zero
okay all right next one we have thunder
and goldsmith
you know thunderous all right hands up
to your glass menu
what let's understand all right one two
three
wow this is actually pretty hard because
all of our songs are our favorites but
our favorite song would have to be
thunderous yes
yes nice nice thank you buzzfeed this
was fun and hope to see you again soon
and so be sure to check out our second
album no easy
[Music]
you